herzlich willkommen zur dritten sieht
vorstellung bzw ich habe ich eigentlich
schon viel mehr gemacht aber zu dritten
in dieser neuen reihe die ich jetzt
vorgeschlagen habe wie immer wenn ihr
morgen wieder her eine sieg vorstellung
haben wollt dann könnt ihr mal die 2000
like schaffen sagt resch schafft ihr das
oder schaffte das nicht das ist jetzt
natürlich die frage was das denn
wir gehen hier wieder den
singleplayer-modus create eine neue welt
die ihn dann wir diesmal fsf ist lieber
wir sind immer sdf drin weil ich einfach
immer mit der linken hand dann einfach
drauf rum klopp auf der tastatur sieht
ist red dawn update alles groß
geschrieben
die welt retten wir uns einfach mal der
zieht ist nicht unglaublich extraordinär
osten
ich würde eher sagen dass es ein toller
sieht es aber als kein unglaublich geil
aussieht des kopierens fenster komische
leute also wir wirklich total aus dem
konzept gebracht
es ist kein keinen richtig geiler osim
fucking mega super geiler sieht sondern
einfach ein ganz normaler seed mit ein
paar extras und zwar starten wir hier
hier allgemein hier schon so eine coole
höhle oder so kann man sich bestimmt was
rein kommt man hier auch relativ leicht
durch so einen coolen gang zum strand
gang zum staat und diese regime zieht
sich hier durch das komplette mpc dorf
kann man ja einfach hier so einem
untergrund weg bauen so kann man hier
wieder hoch irgendwie so könnte man ja
mal bauen
wie immer wenn ihr sowas wort können wir
wieder und sanieren wir auf jeden fall
eine menge cobblestone wegen nehmen
brunnen oder und robbt sich taktischen
hessen das ist für wasser partikel der
brunnen hat natürlich was eigentlich
na ja also das ist auf jeden fall die
startpositionen die man and pc doch
direkt am start ist natürlich cool hat
allerdings keine schmiede das ist eher
suboptimal
da hinten an den park krasse berge seht
ihr jetzt rechts eingeblendet auch sehr
schön und was wir hier auch noch finden
ist einfach eine savanne wo man
mit sicherheit coole sachen bauen kann
weil hier ist anderen strand bzw in den
see ist da und der see ist halt einfach
perfekt er hat jeden strand da hinten
ist winter hier ist auch noch mal so ein
kleiner see
also sind einfach perfekt gesehen weil
schaut und schaut euch das mal einfach
an
von der von der tiefe hier werte so die
kamera also nicht zu tief aber auch
nicht zu flach also ich bin jetzt hier
gerade auf dem boden und er ist wirklich
überall so als es ist perfekt das sieht
ich könnte mal ganz kurz kann ich hier
nicht irgendwie quality clearwater
ungenau genau jetzt seht ihr hier so ein
bisschen perfekter kann hier so ein
bisschen durchgucken seht ihr auch dass
sie hier auf jeden fall eventuell so ein
bisschen was finden könnte wartet
gewinnt nicht hier wo ich ihn jetzt so
warte und zwar haben wir hier ich habe
ja gesagt mit ein paar extras so und
zwar haben wir direkt unter dem see hier
direkt
wir haben direkt an mein chef trinks
drin bums und direkt noch eine weitere
revision durcheinander stronghold das
heißt allerdings sind hier noch
natürlich eine menge tiere und hier ist
ein grad h beziehungsweise so etwas
coolere höhle also wenn jetzt nicht
unbedingt der minecraft der seite der
meint hey ich will hier mit 15 diamanten
direkt am start starten und dann will
ich auch noch in stronghold direkt haben
und alles klar
hier habt ihr einfach ansieht wo er
direkt zum möglichkeiten habt und sport
noch nicht gesehen was ich hier soll es
drinnen und nicht so gut gesehen habt
ihr direkt ein paar anfangs sachen halt
womit ihr euch am anfang ein bisschen
gut zurechtkommen sind nicht perfekt so
wie mir diamanten sondern halt so für
den typischen minecraft ansporn ein
bisschen was ihr zum einen dann haben
wäre natürlich fliegt hier wieder zurück
hier natürlich etwas größere höhle die
auch so schön aussieht dahinter mit dem
pc wird um ein bisschen traden kann hier
allgemein die landschaft derselben zum
bauen allgemeine die savanne dahinten
paar berge wenn man einen kletter brücke
drauf machen will also sondern ein
typischer sieht einfach ein paar kinder
selten als in diamant gut das war es auf
jeden fall mit diesem zieht wenn ihr die
nächste vorstellung haben wollt wie
schon gesagt 2000 likes und die
comdirect morgen müssen wir einfach
schauen ob die wirtschaft
der türke war einfach okay aber jetzt
will ich erst noch ich will eigentlich
greift ja immer so nach oben und drückt
dann darauf den knopf bei der kamera
jetzt will ich gerade zum bildschirm
greifen hier so zac und auf das flex auf
die roten zahlen drücken damit das
ausgeht er ich bin doch sonst klappt
einfach nur